of course they've also been enjoying you
in Game of Thrones again in season three
very much so as Purcell I mean what was
your reaction to such a dramatic season
the red wedding for example what did you
think when you saw that wow what do you
think when you saw that well I got it by
audition for part I have read for
several parts in fact I only got this
one because an actor happened to be ill
that was going to do it Roy dotrice who
is now much better and he's now back in
the series in another part which is
wonderful and I play this Oh black of
104 whose situation is that he survived
because he always backed the right horse
and if he doesn't they make sure he does
next time and he is determined to he
knows he's gonna die he should be dead
already but these days he's going to die
and but he wants to die on his own terms
and sink into the ground in the natural
way and that's why he's still there and
that's why despite the enmity and people
laugh at him and in the court he's in
fact quite valuable to the court his his
advice and his age is valuable it's not
a large part of the viewers will know
but it's jolly good to play and I loved
doing it absolutely lovely except the
beard is so uncomfortable
oh god when we're filming out in
Dubrovnik in the heat it's like having
an ant's nest on your face you would
never know that get rid of the beard
pycelle what advice would you give him
for season four going forward how can he
keep keep alive and keep his wits about
him pycelle by doing what he's doing i
mean it's um he's in fact living two
lives and that's the one life which is
in the court when he's all doddery that
still gives the advice and there's the
other life when he's acting like a young
man with women and
and as fit as a flea and all that but he
deliberately covers that up in public
and at this point in the series were in
serious for now only two people who know
that he's two people and I hope that's
going to be exploited the thing is he's
not essential to the plot if I sell he's
like he's not essential to the court but
he's useful and that's why they keep him
around and so the part is useful as a
sort of sounding board for the writers
but it's not essential so they could get
rid of me at any time I don't think he's
worth getting rid of do you know what I
mean
it he doesn't deserve a really dramatic
death I mean you're gonna see some more
that I it's yes it when you first read
the script I couldn't I couldn't believe
ever sewed nine of the first series when
Sean Bean gets his head cut off and I've
read the script I thought Sean beans the
hamlet of the series he's the great one
we will love and associated with and I
went back to the beginning of the script
thinking I have missed something I know
this is such a weird series I've missed
something I went through it in really
detail every single scene even once he
wasn't dealing or not no case his head
chopped off and that's what's brave
about the series it doesn't mind just
Punk and there you know people come and
go mostly go and I'm enough of course
liberty to reveal those who've read the
books will know but now we're starting
to go slightly outside the books and the
writers has taken more liberties like I
said there's a there's at least two
maimings and one what you can call
lovemaking sequence in each episode
which keeps people alive it keeps people
interested turn the box I've had lots of
spectacular death so far but which ones
really stand out for you the death of
the horse
it was absolutely horrifying cutting
that horse's head off it was
that was well it was somehow dan Shawn
going it was so so unfair you know you
could say the Sean's character people
could blame him for doing all sorts of
things
not that you deserved at his head cut
off but you know the horse just the
horse got God and they had a thing like
in you know that's America the Godfather
I hit that head in the bed and that was
lying around on the set of course for
further use it was so violent that is my
personally might but however there's one
coming up which is going to make you
laugh so much but I'm not going to tell
you what it is I mean as we say we've
lost so many people on the show haven't
we great actors and great characters if
you could bring anybody back to life in
Game of Thrones absolutely none they all
dispensable but we like you the human
animal is dispensable and I think that's
a wonderful observation on the show it
is ruthless it's violent it's sexier all
those things but we are all dispensable
and they are proving that they can do
without their Hamlet they can do it out
there Horatio or their Benedict or them
or a Coriolanus or whatever they because
the things go on because it's so
fantastically placed historically
there's nowhere at all
nowhere in history at all that the
history in in Game of Thrones is
thousands of years old then and when
where is it when is it and so they can
use artifacts from all over the world to
decorate their sets and then their
clothes and all that and everything
looks worn and a part of people's life
you can smell that series and which is
mistake that's some serious you won't be
mentioned the make that you there so
brightens and fantastic and and and
polished and cuts and cut out carefully
and all that I really don't feel people
are actually living up there in scam
with friends I believe it's people I
really do believe the people and it
appeals to the basest instincts in all
of us have you found
she sings season four compared to the
previous seasons that you chart the same
thing you just didn't know what's around
the corner when you do could you've read
your script the time you come in just
started an episode you think I can't
believe what's going to happen it's
really going to happen isn't it oh yes
it's going to happen then it got guests
to it and you think they can't film this
this is something that they're not going
to be able to film they do because there
are all magicians magicians so at the
San Diego comic-con this year there was
a very fantastic scene revealed that had
been deleted unfortunately from the last
season of Game of Thrones with you
pycelle and Tywin Lannister Charles
dance and what did you enjoy about that
scene and do you feel a bit sad that it
being cut from the show I felt very sad
that it was cut from the show the fans
can of course get is however it might
not because I talk to the directors
about I was only out there last week two
weeks ago I said I'm really sorry that
went you know and he said yes but quite
often we put things in different
positions and we might find a place for
it elsewhere I said I really hope you do
because it it confirmed the seed that we
had laid earlier on about him being two
things and I enjoyed doing that scene
because I was able to actually say what
it was actually all about I am
determined to die on my own time and I
know I'm gonna croak on him in it but I
want to croak and I don't want to be
killed and to be and I think you saw was
I certainly saw a twinkle in Charlie
dances I'm I'm entertained by by this
this thing that this old bugger is doing
and but we'll keep it to ourselves and I
enjoy doing and was very sorry to hear
that it have been country it's funny
that Tywin was on tea though wasn't it
the only one to come on you think been
getting him out of this for years well
yeah I have been getting away from me
for you but he's extremely good at his
job and he keeps his eyes open
Tyron God chastises good at it isn't it
it's that part of his life is absolutely
made to play that part
absolutely brilliant brilliant yeah
didn't guess did she either would you
know because you've got that scene in
season two you know you're together and
then she leaves and she's getting a
little bit uppity you know or waiting
for this old man to get up and
everything you and you and she's oh I'll
go myself and then as soon as she's gone
Europe and you you are a fan it's been
the most memorable day of shooting on
Game of Thrones so far fee over the full
series it was the execution of Sean Bean
yeah we were out in Malta and it was
horrible doing it well they you know
it's all done in little bits and pieces
so you don't get the horror of the
build-up but also unpleasant and and you
know the little girl watching her father
and and awful and that dreadful young
man that came they've got t-shirts now
that I think go with jof and watch it
off and yes and that's awful change of
mind he does my wife my all the women
and think ashes express mercy not no not
at all do you like to see it I know what
would you like to see happen to him I'm
not going to tell you all I could say is
I'm like everybody else who ever watched
that says we really want him we want him
out of it that wonderful thing in the
first series when she nearly pushes him
over the over that wall and you're
he doesn't doesn't make her shoulder but
we also wanted it that and that was only
the first series of marriages series for
so no see character okay yeah everyone
about Jack Gleeson says which are lovely
lad here what a lovely young actor yes
and he's not an actor he's never not
going to be an actor he's a most serious
philosophy student and charming boy
charming boy quickly Nathalie humbled
completely nicely unspoiled by all this
he just realizes fantastic he's got the
money to go to university now and wishes
was terrific
but that character he's a he's he's
truly evil because he revels in other
people's discomfort and invents things
in order to make things uncomfortable he
if it has a dinner table you suddenly
realize a little weakness in someone you
put his finger into it and ran in the
wound and and it's just it's truly
properly evil person horrible scene with
them with rose as well you know and when
he when virus cells and not Varys
Littlefinger cells rose to to Joffrey
and he kills her with people can do
because he's Kim and he's got all the
money and he pays all the servants and
he pays all the the army and all that
and nobody can get of him I'm gonna get
him
the only person was any influence on him
soul is another and it's interesting
that because I mean she's a nasty piece
of work but totally protective of him
and he never serious for you get an
inkling of what that's all about of
protectionism
don't wait to see it can't wait to see
some more of you as well in Game of
Thrones it's always too long away what
are you most looking forward to fans of
the show seeing or finding out in season
four I can't tell you I'm not allowed to
I'm not allowed to absolutely sounds
very boring I'm sworn to secrecy I have
my script which says Julian Glover
printed right across it and it's my
script and it mustn't get out must not
ever get out I don't even tell my wife
no and well there was one sequence which
I objected to which I did show my wife
was she said oh don't do that you'll be
on Facebook in five minutes but which we
got over where I was describing the
scripts having to I was revealed to
start naked except for my chain of
office being pleasured by a young woman
and lying on a bed and I thought now we
can do this without that and I'm 104 but
okay so you can still do it but it still
is and it's not good for Julian it's not
good for Julian and so we did it in a
different way exactly the same in the
situation apply but we did it in a
different way and the scene when I get
arrested and bye bye bye Tyrion and that
brilliant actor dinklage peter dinkledge
for what a brilliant actor he is he just
he just knows how to do it listen to us
all as I seen in that series for today
where she just after pure malice comes
and mocks me and it is it was great fun
to do because that naughty girl at
Northey actress this is gorgeous Lena
her eyes were so full of mockery and
amusement at her own success and when
she walked away from the scene she was
old fat Sam Tyree says to her you're in
a good mood today said no simple
pleasures and that's just it and taking
complete piss out of pycelle
however I'm alright
you